Hello, my name's Edward Bennett and I'm an instructor here at Epic Games.
I'd like to welcome you to Tool Creation for version 5.1.
This course was originally written in Unreal Engine 5.1, but the tools are common across all of five.
So you should be fine working in any version of five.
In this course, we're going to start off by going over some toolmaking theory in the engine.
It shouldn't take much more than 10 minutes.
And then the rest of the course is going to be pretty much hands on exercises.
Each of these exercises, there's an expectation that will take around half an hour.
So the first exercise we'll be doing will be on the using the construction script where we will be scattering meshes.
Second exercise, we will be baking out those meshes using the exposed function commands.
Third exercise, we'll be building an editor utility widget to quickly spawn meshes.
And finally, we will be creating a editor asset utility to do some renaming.
So that's it for the introduction.
Let's jump into a bit of theory in the next video.